WRONG.
THE OTHER ANSWER IS A LOT EASIER
THE OTHER ANSWER IS A LOT EASIE
EASIER.
>> Tucker: GENTLEMEN,
THANK YOU BOTH.
THE PARK WHEN SHOOTING APPEARS
TO HAVE HAPPENED DESPITE SOME
ADVANCED WARNING.
THE FBI WAS TIPPED OFF IN A WAY
TO A YOUTUBE COMMENTER WHO IS
DISCUSSING HIS WANT TO BECOME A
PROFESSIONAL SCHOOL SHOOTER.
>> HOW TO BE AFFAIR RESPOND?
TO SPEAK OUT THEY RESPONDED
PRETTY AMAZINGLY.
I HAD A FIELD AGENT CONTACT ME
AND MEET ME IN MY OFFICE THE
VERY NEXT MORNING AND I WASN'T
ABLE TO PROVIDE THEM WITH MUCH.
>> YOU GAVE THEM THE USERS NAME
WHICH IS THE SAME EXACT THING AS
THE SHOOTER.
>> I WISH I HAD MORE TIME AND
EFFORT TO FINDING OUT WHO THE
YEARS AND HE BELONGS TO.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY NIKOLAS
CRUZ AS THERE ARE ON YOUTUBE,
BUT THEY MAY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
FIND OUT WHO THIS PERSON WAS.
>> Tucker: AS YOU HEARD, THE
FBI WAS NOT ABLE TO IDENTIFY
NIKOLAS CRUZ.
>> IN 2017, THE FBI RECEIVED
INFORMATION ABOUT A COMMENT MADE
ON THE YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
THE COMMENT SIMPLY SAID I'M
GOING TO BE A PROFESSIONAL
SCHOOL SHOOTER.
NO OTHER INFORMATION WAS
INCLUDED WITH THAT COMMENT WHICH
WOULD INDICATE A TIME, LOCATION,
OR THE TRUE IDENTITY OF THE
PERSON WHO MADE THE COMMENT.
THE FBI CONDUCTED DATABASE
REVIEWS, CHECKS, BUT WAS UNABLE
TO FURTHER IDENTIFY THE PERSON
WHO ACTUALLY MADE THE COMMENTS.
>> Tucker: WHAT HAPPENED HERE
DO YOU THINK?
>> AT FIRST LOOK, I THINK THE
FBI WORKED WITHIN ITS
GUIDELINES.
THE FBI IS BOUND BY A DOCUMENT
ABOUT THIS THICK.
THEY TAKE THAT BIBLE VERY
SERIOUSLY AND IT'S REALLY A
DOCUMENT THAT'S MEANT TO LIMIT
THE POWER OF THE FBI, KEEP THEM
FROM EXCESS AND THAT GUIDES WHEN
THE CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH THEY
CAN OPEN A CASE, THE TECHNIQUES
THEY CAN USE IN PURSUING A CASE,
VERY OFTEN WHEN THEY MUST CLOSE
A CASE.
WE HEARD THAT CONVERSATION WITH
SOME TERRORISM CASES THAT HAD
BEEN CLOSED AND THEN SO MANY
STRIKES.
WE SAW IT IN BOSTON AND OTHER
PLACES AROUND THE COUNTRY.
THAT DOCUMENT IS INTENDED TO
PROTECT THE ORGANIZATION.
IT'S INTENDED TO PROTECT UNI
FROM FBI EXCESSES.
>> Tucker: HOW DID IT AFFECT
THEM FROM MOVING FORWARD?
>> THERE'S A COUPLE LEVELS OF
CASES THAT THEY CAN WORK.
THE LOWEST LEVEL OF THAT IS
CALLED AN ASSESSMENT.
I HAVE VERY LITTLE INFORMATION
TO START, I DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH
PREDICATION TO START A
PRELIMINARY INQUIRY AND USE ALL
THE FBI'S TOOLS.
I HAVE VERY LITTLE.
THE GUIDANCE OF THE DIALOGUE
ALSO DOES THIS.
THE FBI IS A FEDERAL AGENCY.
HERE ON ITS FACE, YOU MAY HAVE
NEITHER OF THOSE TWO THINGS, YOU
HAVE SOME WORDS THAT SOME WOULD
SAY THAT'S FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
I'M NOT THREATENING SOMEBODY
DIRECTLY, I'M JUST THROWING UP
SOME HATE, SUPPOSITION ON THE
INTERNET AND STIRRING PEOPLE UP.
>> Tucker: THAT'S A FAIR
POINT.
WE'VE BEEN PRETTY TOUGH ON THE
FBI RECENTLY ON THIS SHOW AND A
WAY THAT'S WARRANTED, BUT I ALSO
THINK IN CASES LIKE THIS, ARE WE
INVESTING TOO MUCH CONFIDENCE IN
ALL OF OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT
THEY COULD PREVENT PEOPLE BENT
ON MASS MURDER FROM COMMITTING
IT QUESTION BUT THAT SEEMS LIKE
A LOT TO ASK.
>> IT IS A LOT TO ASK.
LAW ENFORCEMENT ABSOLUTELY HAS
TO TRIED TO CONNECT UP AND I DO
THINK THE FBI PROBABLY OWES US A
LITTLE BIT MORE CLARITY ON WHAT
STEPS THEY TOOK.
HOWEVER, IF I DON'T LIKE
SOMETHING YOU SAY ON THIS SHOW
AND I'M SITTING WITH THE FBI AND
YOU'VE BEEN CRITICAL OF THEM
RECENTLY, THEY DON'T GET TO
START A CASE ON TUCKER AND START
FOLLOWING HIM BECAUSE ONE OF
THOSE THINGS WITH AN AUTHORIZED
PURPOSE IS IT CAN'T BE FOR
PROTECTED FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS
PROTECTED FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT
RIGHTS.
>> CAN YOU TELL US WHAT THE DIAG
IS?
>> IT'S THE HANDBOOK.
THIS THICK.
EVERYONE IS TESTED ON IT, GET
LECTURES ON IT FROM INTERNAL
LEGAL TEAMS.
THEY ADHERE TO THAT, IT'S
AUDITED.
THEIR CONDUCT IS AUDITED,
THERE'S SOMEBODY LOOKING OVER
THEIR SHOULDER TO SAY YOU DID
THIS RIGHT OR YOU'RE OUTSIDE OF
THE BALANCE ON THIS AND THE
FIRST AMENDMENT PROTECTED SPEECH
IS ONE OF THOSE KEY AREAS THAT
THE DIAG TALKS ABOUT REPEATEDLY.
THEY MAY HAVE AN AUTHORIZED
PURPOSE TO START AN ASSESSMENT,
BUT THEY CAN USE VERY FEW TOOLS.
THEY CAN DO DATABASE CHECKS,
OTHER GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND
THAT'S ABOUT IT.
THIS IS NOT THE TYPE OF CASE
WHERE YOU'RE GOING TO THE U.S.
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE AND SAY GIVE
ME A STACK OF SUBPOENAS.
>> Tucker: IF SOMEBODY SAYS
I'M BECOMING A PROFESSIONAL
SCHOOL SHOOTER, WHO KNOWS WHAT
IT MEANS?
BUT IF HE SAYS I'M SCREWING UP
THIS SCHOOL ON THIS DATE --
>> KNOW YOU HAVE A BETTER
STARTING POINT.
IF I'M LISTENING TO THOSE WORDS
AND I HAVE THIS EXPERIENCE, ONE
OF MY FIRST QUESTIONS IS IS THIS